ja ein sehr emotionaler auftritt herren
welche reaktionen haben sie darauf
bekommen
bis zur stunde
explodiert alles was ich so an
eingangs möglichkeiten von nachrichten
habe das studios noch einmal potenziert
in letzter zeit
etwas schreiben wir die leute was sagen
die leute
naja also grundsätzlich werden wir ja
sowieso von vielen orts- kräften und
unterstützern
angeschrieben und um hilfe gebeten das
ist jetzt sicherlich nicht weniger
geworden aber auch viele
zustimmungen viel
unterstützung
angeboten
patenschaften zu übernehmen für
ortskräfte für mich ist das feedback
fast zu 100 prozent sehr positiv ein tag
nach diesen beiden gründen auch eine art
ausbruch den wir da gesehen haben gab es
ja gestern die große debatte im
bundestag teil der linkspartei hat sich
enthalten
weil es ist um die frage der evakuierung
gegen größte evakuierungsmaßnahmen der
bundeswehr in ihrer geschichte was denkt
man sich darüber hat man so eine
enthaltung da muss ich sagen ich habe
dass mir das dem mandat text bisher
nicht durchgelesen ich bin fokussiert
auf das was in und um kabul passiert ich
komme nicht mal dazu den orts kräften
die es geschafft haben mit oder ohne
unsere unterstützung irgendwie mal hallo
zu sagen da hätte ich auch sehr viel
bedarf daran eigentlich aber wir sind
ein volk kopf fokussiert und ganz
ehrlich der
mandatstext hat für mich jetzt sehr
nicht die entscheidende rolle gespielt
in unserem jeglichen versuch den
ortskräfte zu helfen und wie fanden sie
die rede der kanzlerin
naja sie erwähnte 2500 ortskräfte die
aufnahme zusagen bekommen haben und dann
brauchte man irgendwann keine visa mehr
dazwischen lagen in meinem und unserer
wahrnehmung circa zwei zweieinhalb
monate und in diesen zweieinhalb monaten
oder zwei monaten genau vom 16 06
angaben ist eine personengruppe die war
visa berechtigt und denen haben wir
versucht diese visa zu ermöglichen und
bis zum fall kabuls haben wir es nicht
geschafft bis dann
montag die safe häuser geräumt werden
mussten letzte woche weil ja die taliban
von haus zu haus ging safe häuser können
sie einmal kurz erklären ja wir hatten
die idee den orts kräften die den
aufenthalt in kabul zu ermöglichen denn
dort ist nicht nur der flughafen sondern
auch ein un büro sollte dort sein um
gefährdungs anzeigen und visa prozesse
zu dem ergebnis die internationale
organisation für migration rechtlich
genau und da haben wir halt gedacht wenn
wir den orts kräften noch irgendwo einen
sicheren aufenthalt halbwegs sicheren
aufenthalt geben können dann dort wo sie
die nötigen dokumente beibringen können
um in ein flugzeug zu steigen auch ein
passwort kann ich auf afghanischer seite
in kabul
durchlaufen oder bekommen insofern war
kabul dann für uns der letzte strohhalm
nehmen sie uns vormittag wie muss man
sich das vorstellen was sind das für
leute über die wir jetzt unsere lange
zeit in der deutschen öffentlichkeit
auch diskutieren die sogenannten
ortskräfte hätten wir bei dieser begriff
vor nicht so richtig geläufig wäre
kotierte was machen die wie wichtig sind
die wo sind die also ortskräfte sind wie
der generalinspekteur mal so schön sagte
für den einsatz der bundeswehr in einem
land wo man die sprache zum beispiel
nicht spricht unablässig und sie kann
man nicht wirken denn wir brauchen
menschen die uns die sprache übersetzen
die kultur übersetzen aber auch so
sachen machen wie uns bewachen zum
beispiel denn jeder soldat der sich
selbst bewachen muss ist nicht dazu da
und oder kann nicht in der fläche wirken
und so sind viele viele militärischen
aufgaben werden erst möglich weil wir
ortskräfte haben weil uns jemand die
sprache übersetzt und die kultur und die
werden von der bundesrepublik
deutschland den verschiedenen
ministerien angestellt haben vertrag
sozusagen einen richtigen vertrag das
sind dann ortskräfte die für die
verschiedenen ministerien arbeiten und
und der der deal ist vielleicht das
falsche wort in dem zusammenhang aber
das geschäft besteht darin dass man sich
gegenseitig auch vertrauen schenkt also
das heißt die verlassen sich darauf wenn
irgendetwas passiert wenn's schief geht
dann nehmt die uns mit holt uns daraus
also grundsätzlich ist das sicherlich
nicht der erste gedanke den die haben
wenn die uns unterstützen die haben wer
zehn jahre oder länger für uns
gearbeitet hat der hat das sicherlich
auch getan weil er gehofft hat dass
unsere ziele die wir verwirklichen
wollten dass wir da erfolgreich waren
hat ja erst mal keiner ist vom worst
case szenario ausgegangen dass das
irgendwann zu einem scheitern führen
könnte und insofern bin ich mir nicht
sicher ob da überhaupt jemals einer
vorher drüber nachgedacht hat nicht
glaube einfach dass jemand der in einem
arbeitsverhältnis mit uns steht und
dessen existenz dann für die durch die
arbeit für uns bedroht ist oder sein
leben bedroht ist dass wir dem hyde in
einem gewissen ein gewisses
entgegenkommen schön da geht es um
vertrauen ich denke da geht es einmal um
moralische werte wie wir mit menschen
die wir selber einstellen und
beschäftigen wie man mit denen umgehen
aber es auch in strategische relevanz
denn ortskräfte wenn wir die dringend
brauchen um unseren auftrag zu erfüllen
dann ist es ja wichtig dass wir menschen
einstellen können auch in anderen
ländern wo wir die sprache nicht
sprechen zum beispiel und dann ist es ja
ganz gut wenn die wissen wenn was
passiert dann kümmern wir uns um euch
und diese unterschiedlichen zahlen mit
denen da immer operiert wird jetzt auch
politisch geht auch gleich an sie die
frage hier
2.500 heiko maas davon gesprochen daher
sind vielleicht 2000 leute wenn wir es
aus denen sind plötzlich 20.000 wie
viele sind es denn nun wirklich
an welcher stelle haben wir uns
sozusagen wirklich schuldig gemacht an
welcher stelle haben wir da versagt ja
also in unseren augen sind das circa
10.000 mords kräfte und
familienmitglieder kernfamilie denn wir
müssen wir mal sagen rechnen wir nur
ortskräfte oder mit familie dann ist es
mal fünf multipliziert und wenn man sagt
2500 und davon sind 1900 hier dann ist
das mit familie und dann muss ich halt
die 10.000 in relation setzen die wir
beschäftigt haben davon sind einige
nicht antragsberechtigt oder waren es
nicht das haben wir kritisiert dahin
über hinaus sind halt dann auch noch
personen mit als subunternehmer
beschäftigt aber das sind extra also wir
reden jetzt bei 10.000 nur von orts
kräften und ihren familienangehörigen
und da hätte man halt finden wir von
vornherein eine idee oder ein konzept
haben müssen wer antragsberechtigt ist
und wie die nachsorge aussieht und
nachsorge ist für uns schwierig wenn wir
erst nach hause fliegen und dann gucken
dass es nach sorge gibt sondern das
hätte man hat vielleicht wie mit dem
gerät auch nicht irgendwo stehen lassen
und dann schauen dass alles gut geht
sondern das hätte man halt bevor man den
schlüssel ab gibt und sagt wir sind
nicht mehr da hätte man sich um diese
ortskräfte auch kümmern müssen und ich
sehe auch nicht den das argument dass
irgendwie dann der da ein pull effekt
oder wie auch immer oder das dass das
land dann da zugrunde gegangen wäre das
sind menschen die beschäftigen wir ja
schon gar nicht mehr ab wann war ihnen
klar auf welche situationen wieder
hinaus laufen ist ganz interessant denn
dieser runde sitzen sitzen mehrere leute
die das sehr klar und deutlich haben
kommen sehen sie gehören dazu gerd kraus
gehört dazu hat man bei ihnen klar
worauf das hinausläuft wann wird klar
was da passieren könnte also dass die
taliban tatsächlich fast ohne widerstand
dieses ganze land einfach überrennen und
also ich mach das an
33 events fest das eine war ein twitter
oder eine nachrichtenmeldungen des
deutschen einsatzkontingentes was in den
letzten tagen in masar i scharif
ungefähr sagte wir können uns selbst
verteidigen wenn ein deutsches
einsatzkontingent in masar i scharif
ende juni sagt wir können uns selbst
verteidigen dann ist das jetzt ja nicht
die botschaft die hören möchte wenn ich
mir denke da sind noch lauter ortskräfte
und kurz darauf war das kontingent dann
ja auch da auf dem rückflug und heißt es
da bald klar da spitzt sich die lage
also wenn das deutsche kontingent quasi
vor den taliban wegfliegt dann waren da
ja immer noch ortskräfte den haben wir
dann versucht mit inlandsflügen masar i
scharif war ja schon eingekesselt der
sprecher auswärtiges amt sagte dann wir
sind man kann ja ab und zu kann man ja
also masar i scharif ist nicht ständig
eingekesselt manchmal können sie ja auf
dem land marsch nach kabul das ist so
als wenn ich einen revolver auf den
tisch lege und sage sind nicht alle kann
man gefüllt drücken sie doch mal kann ja
gut kann ja gut gehen russisch roulette
sozusagen ja das fand ich fand dich
reicht nicht und dann haben wir versucht
mit flugtickets die menschen nach kabul
zu bringen weil wir gesagt haben kabul
wird als letztes stehen aber als
beispiel am vierten august gab es einen
komplexen anschlag auf den
verteidigungsminister afghanistans mit
mehreren selbstmordattentätern in kabul
13 tote aber der verteidigungsminister
überlebte zwei tage später wurde der
sprecher der regierung erschossen in
kabul
und da ist nicht irgendwie der der
eindruck entstanden dass das irgendwie
zeit kritisch ist es gab immer noch
nicht ein visum was begonnen wurde von
der personengruppe die seit dem 16 6
auch auf druck der kanzlerin wie sei
berechtigt gewesen wäre nicht ein visum
wurde begonnen in unseren nach unserer
wahrnehmung und ein visum hat als der
generalinspekteur die wisag mit dem
köfferchen selber in den einsatz
geflogen hat mindestens vier bis sechs
wochen gedauert es war also aus unserer
sicht dann zu sagen ja aber kabul hält
ja noch 30 tage
selbst wenn sofort visa begonnen werden
wären die menschen nicht mehr im
flugzeug gewesen
und wir legen wert auf diese wiese was
haben sie gemacht wann haben sie
angefangen darauf hinzuweisen haben sie
telefonate geführt haben sie in berlin
den scheidenden leute angeschrieben was
haben sie gemacht ich habe insgesamt im
namen unseres vereins und
internationaler organisationen darauf
mit mit fünf briefen an das kanzleramt
wagen sucht hinzuweisen dann waren in
der ersten juni beginnend bis in den
juli hinein
apropos im august war das die lage dann
so dynamisch dass wir dann letztendlich
und ich habe auch nie eine antwort
bekommen deshalb oft kalten dieser
brieflein wenn man wenn man fünf briefe
schreibt dann ist der sechste irgendwie
dann auch ein bisschen traurig aber da
dazu ist es dann nicht mehr gekommen
denn die über ereignisse haben sich dann
zu schnell geschlagen wir haben versucht
mehr safe häuser zu einzurichten waren
gerade dabei die häuser 4 5 und 6
aufzubauen und im zuge dessen als kabul
dann gefallen ist mussten wir sie dann
aber auflösen kozak zimmermann wie kann
es sein dass da jemand sitzt der sich
auskennt mit der situation vor ort der
schreibt fünfmal der sagt sehr laut und
deutlich da gibt es bald ein problem der
wand und mahnt wir müssen daraus wie
kann das sein wenn sie mich das vor vier
jahren gefragt hätten werde ich gesagt
das kann nicht sein heute weiß ich es
kann sein weil wir eine komplette
verantwortung die fusion haben das heißt
wir haben mehrere ministerien
außenministerium verteidigung in dem
fall innenministerium logic luisa und
entwicklung übrigens letzteres herr
müller hat sich relativ in der
diskussion wer hat jetzt fehler gemacht
sich relativ in den schatten gestellt um
nicht aufzufallen letzteres übrigens
auch herr seehofer waren die beiden
minister die
ganz lange verhindert haben also schon
im april als das thema klar war dass wir
ortskräfte evakuieren das waren die
beiden wie irgendwie war das klar also
immer
auch schon im april darüber bestürzt hat
sie in der tat getan das war auch immer
im verteidigungsausschuss ein thema denn
es gab der daten wir wussten bis ende
april muss die bundeswehr aus also zur
erinnerung
präsident trump hat die taliban hoffähig
gemacht hat mit ihnen ein deal gemacht
in doha wurde in doha
deutlich vorher es wurde ein
abzugstermin gemacht ohne bedingungen
zumindest bedingungen die für uns von
relevanz gewesen wäre thema was passiert
mit den frauen wenn wir gehen was
passiert mit den menschenrechten also
das spielt alles keine rolle es war ein
die wir gehen terror darf nicht mehr
zurückkommen und gefangenenaustausch das
war's so die daten standen fest dann kam
die administration beiden und biden hat
sich ausbedungen ein monat zu schauen
die geht die lage und ich räume ein dass
auch wir gedacht haben er wird da jetzt
geschwindigkeit rausnehmen und plötzlich
wohl ging es doch noch schneller es war
dann im grunde genommen orientierte man
sich an ein eleven also dem zu jahrestag
des momentums was den afghanistan
einsatz ausgelöst hat plötzlich war der
vierte juli amerikanischen
nationalfeiertag er ins spiel das heißt
plötzlich orientierte sind sich die
alliierten an den feiertagen der
amerikaner und das ganze hat eine solche
geschwindigkeit aufgenommen wir wussten
also wir müssen bis ende april raus und
somit war klar wenn wir aus dem norden
afghanistans verschwinden können unsere
ortskräfte haben ja gar keine anlauf
möglichkeit mehr was gerade gesagt wurde
in sie aufzufordern nach kabul zu reisen
wo danach neu delhi oder nach islamabad
ist ja bei allem respekt völlig katar
und dass das war so das war hat man ihn
angeboten aber das ist natürlich ich
meine das ist ja keine wissen sie das
sind ja keine blühenden landschaften wo
sie dann mal reisen also ich meine ich
durfte einmal mit ministerin von der
leyen einige tage in afghanistan seien
bei die soldaten soldatin er war ein
kabul das ist wissen sie dass das sind
kriegsähnliche zustände klatscht man
nicht einfach so rein unser carlo hat
kann man die so lange rede kurzer sinn
das ganze war mit ansage und
offensichtlich wollte er seehofer und
herr müller nicht dass im wahlkampf
bundestagswahlkampf das thema und das
ist entscheidend
wir holen jetzt flüchtlinge wieder nach
deutschland bloß nicht das sollte aus
diesem
bundestagswahl bereich rausgehalten
werden und deswegen sollte man mal dahin
gucken wo diese fehler gemacht wurden
neben dem missmanagement von heiko maas
im außenministerium herr klaus wenn man
sich das mal vor stellt also ich will
jetzt orts kraft irgendwo in kundus oder
marsa el scharif oder wo auch immer aber
der seit jahren für die bundeswehr für
die nato für bin auch immer verlass mich
auf die und dann höre ich plötzlich bist
du brauchst antrag du brauchst du visum
da kommt die ganze deutsche bürokratie
plötzlich so stelle ich mir das konkret
vor ich muss da durch ein land reisen
möglicherweise mit dokumenten mit
unterlagen die ich ja denn in kabul oder
wo auch immer vorlegen muss die
sozusagen dokumentieren dass ich den
anspruch habe auf ein solches visum dann
komme ich doch auf dem weg dahin in
straßensperren dann komme ich doch
möglicherweise irgendwann an punkte an
denen genau diese dokumente die das
belegen könnten für mich zu leichten
todesgefahr werden das heißt wo fängt
denn die fehlerkette der an das so
simpel stelle ich mir das vor wie ist
das so
also
eine gruppe von freunden die sich in
afghanistan sehr gut auskennt hat sich
an mich gewandt anfang mai und gesagt
die situation ist dramatisch
wir schreiben hier einen brief der wurde
dem spiegel veröffentlicht das war
glaube ich mitte mai
auch die soldaten viele viele hohe
offiziere und militärs waren dabei
afghanistan experten die alle gesehen
haben hier hier läuft das ganz ganz
schief und ich habe mir gedacht okay
dass so ein brief wird reaktionen
auslösen weil ja 20 jahre lang darüber
gesprochen wurde wie
existenziell diese mission ist
weil ja absehbar war nach diesem
abkommen von trump
das hier vor amerika die priorität war
einfach abzuziehen koste es was es wolle
und weil man eine moralische
verpflichtung hat was wir dann gesehen
haben also ich finde es ja immer noch
bestürzt und wenn man zurückgeht am
vierten august der anschlag auf den
verteidigungsminister
ich glaube ein oder zwei tage später
haben die amerikaner aufgerufen alle
amerikaner sollen das land verlassen und
in diese situation hinein am 5 august
kommt ein brief an die europäische
kommission denen der deutsche
innenminister mitunter schreibt welch
unglaublich da steht drinnen die
priorität in diesem moment für die
europäische union in gesprächen mit der
afghanischen regierung sollte sein
sicherzustellen dass noch ein abschiebe
flug stattfindet also am 5 august zehn
tage bevor kabul feld okay es war nicht
so schlimm wie in österreich wo die
afghanische botschafterin in der zeit
einberufen wurde und die regierung sich
protestiert hat die botschafterin ins
außenministerium zitiert haben gesagt
hat warum lasst ihr keine abflüge mehr
zu das war tage bevor kabul gefallen ist
und jetzt frage ich mich also zwei
offensichtliche fragen wenn im
innenministerium der innenminister der
das unterschrieben hat im moment daran
denkt die afghanische regierung hat
schon wochen davor gebeten bitte das
geht jetzt nicht die sicherheitslage ist
katastrophal in dem moment daran denkt
die priorität der eu ist nicht darüber
nachzudenken wien holen wir raus sondern
irgend einen flug noch mal schnell den
letzten flug nach kabul schicken wo dann
ein paar leute drin sitzen das dass die
priorität sein soll da frage ich mich
was war die analyse wusste ja nicht was
los ist oder weiß einem egal und diese
diese der focus hat einmal einfach
vollkommen falsch
frage an herrn kuban wenn gott ja das
wusste wenn er klaus das wusste wenn
frau stark zimmermann das wusste warum
wusste dass der deutsche innenminister
nicht also erstmal will ich sagen also
wenn ich das höre was sehr gut an hier
schildert was ihren letzten tagen von
ihm gehört habe dann lässt einen das
wirklich ein flaues gefühl im magen weil
man darüber nachdenkt das sind ja das
sind freunde das sind partner das sind
leute die uns vor ort geholfen haben da
durch diese schwere gebiet durch ein
ungewohntes gebiet für unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten zu kommen und
deswegen finde ich das so schwierig dass
man die ganze zeit diejenigen hier auch
diese ganze die flüchtlings debatte
damit auf zieht weil das sind leute die
haben uns vor ort geholfen das waren
unsere partner sollten sie auch nur
deswegen der satz 2015 darf sich nicht
wiederholen können wir gerne darüber
reden aber das wird vielleicht mal
vorweg stellen und deswegen sage ich
auch wir sollten jetzt alles dafür tun
um diejenigen stellt es möglich da raus
zu holen und wir werden mit sicherheit
auch über politische konsequenzen reden
auch über die frage wer wusste wann was
aber jetzt muss doch im vordergrund
stehen schnellstmöglich noch alle
diejenigen zu retten und denjenigen zu
helfen den wir irgendwie noch retten
können noch mal die frage die union hat
dagegen gestimmt im juni gegen den
antrag der grünen
linke fdp hatte ihren eigenen antrag
sozusagen sie waren dagegen sagten
also ich bin nicht teil des deutschen
bundestages schweizer ist aber die cdu
sie sind sozusagen heute teil der
zeitung hat es gut bin ich und bleibe
ich auch war das ein fehler ich würde
sagen eben gerade hat es ja auch gesagt
dass die kanzlerin sich auch sehr
persönlich dafür eingesetzt hat dass es
stärkere visa erleichterungen gibt und
dass man auch auf diesem weg nicht nur
zusätzliche listen oder zusätzliche
gruppen visa erleichtert sondern eben
dass es mehr visa erleichterungen gibt
aber das ist dann am ende von der
bürokratie nicht ausgeführt worden und
das ist etwas was wir glaube ich im
nachhinein noch mal diskutieren müssen
cdu rat dagegen gestimmt das muss erst
mal darüber sprechen ich war dass es am
ende schon verwaltungshandeln von seiten
der kanzlerin gegeben hat und wir merken
das ja jetzt auch ich sehe schon dass im
kanzleramt momentan sehr intensiv sehr
akribisch daran gearbeitet wird das wir
mögen die leute auf diese liste bekommen
ja ja wir werden mit sicherheit wir
werden mit sicherheit über politische
angeht eine annegret kramp karrenbauer
hat ja auch sehr deutlich gesagt dass
sie sich selbst hinterfragen wird und im
zweifel auch politische konsequenzen
ziehen würde ich fand sie da sehr klar
und deswegen jetzt geht es aber darum
denjenigen zu helfen diejenigen zu
retten und die daraus zu holen aber
sie haben von der fassungslosigkeit
gesprochen die sie befällt wenn sie die
das abschieben von verantwortung hören
wenn sie das hören
was geht ihnen durch den kopf
also ich hätte mir gewünscht dass es
deutlichere
verantwortlichkeiten gebe die
verantwortung die fusion die wir
wahrgenommen haben die bis zum schluss
durchgezogen wurde wenn man das ziel
einer
bürokratischen handlung mal hinterfragen
würde warum machen wir da eine aufnahme
für ortskräfte um menschen in sicherheit
zu bringen dann hat es 10 15
verschiedene möglichkeiten und wege
gegeben und punkte neuralgische punkte
wo man sich nicht dazu entschieden hat
dass jetzt schnell durchzuführen sondern
die bewährten verfahren weiter
durchzuführen und diese bewährten
verfahren die man immer wieder machen
würde tut mir leid da ist das ergebnis
nicht akzeptabel und dann muss ich sagen
sind diese bewährten verfahren in jedem
ministerium zu hinterfragen bzw der
gesamtprozess wie von selbst dass das
cdu csu dass die titel gestimmt haben
ich habe die begründung nicht verstanden
ich hätte damit leben können wenn ich
die verstanden hätte vielleicht man hat
ja gesagt eine general aufnahme also wie
eine sammel aufnahme kann nicht
stattfinden denn man muss eine
einzelfallbetrachtung bei jedem der
anderen antrag stellt machen
gleichzeitig haben wir aber überhaupt
kein problem damit gehabt eine sammel
ablehnung zu machen nämlich jeder der
vor zwei jahren oder länger für uns
gearbeitet hat jeder der noch nie eine
gefährdung sun zeige gestellt hat jeder
der für das verteidigungsministerium
erst
im jahr 2012 gearbeitet hat die sind
sammeln abgelehnt und das muss man halt
auch bedenken die sind bis in die
letzten stunden waren die nicht
auflisten weil man gesagt hat die sind
nicht antragsberechtigt und dadurch hat
man zwar eine schöne kleine zahl und
wenn ich dann sage 2500 und davon sind
1900 hier aber wie gesagt es gibt echte
ortskräfte die waren einfach nicht
antragsberechtigt und ja dann muss ich
sagen wenn ich wenn ich die
einzelfallbetrachtung möchte die habe
ich auch immer gewollt nämlich für jeden
jeder müsste eine einzelfallbetrachtung
hätte die verdient gehabt um dann zu
entscheiden oder dass ein gremium dann
sagt ja oder nein damit hätte ich leben
können aber nicht teils teils